scenes like this are the main reason
Japan is struggling to contain its
coronavirus outbreak according to the
country's prime minister the medical
situation on the ground is under
pressure to relieve this pressure if
even by a little and to protect your own
lives and health we would like you to
refrain from going out the number of
cases in Japan has exceeded 11,000 while
Tokyo is still reporting more than a
hundred new infections daily but locking
down the country is not straightforward
despite it being under a state of
emergency the Constitution makes it
impossible to legally enforce social
distancing and the traditional work
culture discourages remotes working it's
in stark contrast to Hong Kong which has
imposed tough social distancing
restrictions and encouraged people to
work from home and that seems to have
paid off for more than a week the city
had only single-digit daily increases in
infections and on Monday recorded none
but Hong Kong's government isn't taking
any chances
despite the adverse impact on the
economy was indeed a very very difficult
balancing act you are right that on the
one hand we want to fight the virus to
keep our citizens safe but on the other
hand if the city is dead it doesn't have
any business people do not have normal
activities that becomes also very very
difficult the government announced it
will extend the measures for another two
weeks
Hong Kong people have been here before
the number of these daily infections
fell to zero in early March but soon
after the city was hit by a second wave
some blame people letting their guard
down too soon and the number of imported
cases rose as Hong Kong residents rushed
home to escape a growing outbreak
overseas from Wednesday all passengers
arriving are required to stay at a
testing centre or a hotel until the
coronavirus results are in less than a
month ago Singapore was hailed as an
example of a success story in avoiding a
major outbreak but now it has the
highest rate of infection in Southeast
Dasia suffering more than a thousand new
cases a day this week mostly among
migrant workers making the city a
cautionary tale and a lesson in what can
happen when vulnerable members of the
population are overlooked the V Gopala
and al Jazeera Hong Kong